well it is motivational Monday here on
the show and I love how you motivate
women like you're you really get behind
them and you want him to feel good like
was it always so natural for you no
absolutely not I was a short chubby
brown you know daughter of immigrants
very little money like dreaming of being
in the entertainment industry and
everyone around me was like what's your
backup plan cuz that sounds crazy people
used to ask me all the time me so angry
yeah yeah and so and you know the very
first movie I ever did was a movie
called real women have curves and I was
17 you know I had to play this girl I
had to take my clothes I'd be my in my
bra and underwear and like dance like
you know on camera and I had to play
this character with so much confidence
about her body and like and I could act
it but you know and people watched that
movie and gained so much confidence like
watching it and and felt so represented
but at the same time I was just a 17
year old girl kind of coming to terms
with my own body image and and so that
was hard but I feel like ultimately I'm
now in an in an amazing place where my
relationship to my body is about
celebration and not about punishment i
chained for triathlons like starting in
2016
and so when I got pregnant I was like in
triathlon shape or whatever I was very
strong and healthy and then I had a baby
and you know my body can do both of
those things I can you know train for a
triathlon and my body shows up for me in
the ways I asked it to and it created
life and brought this baby into the
world and fed this baby you know and and
to mourn you know one past version of my
body versus celebrating what it is now
and and and what it did what it did for
me what it did for my son would be a
shame and so and I'm sure my body would
look like a hundred other things in the
course of my lifetime
dorami to by now like I'm just committed
to loving my body and being so grateful
to be in it everything so
great attitude I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this